como que a educação pode ajudar as
pessoas a alcançarem os seus sonhos e
qual que é a importância disso
na sociedade em que a gente vive hoje eu
vou contar três histórias pra vocês
quando eu tinha 14 anos os meus pais
sempre me davam uma mesada
então todo mês eu recebi um dinheirinho
e eu tinha a possibilidade de escolher o
que eu ia fazer com esse dinheiro
se eu ia comprar tudo em um lanche ou se
eu queria economizar para o futuro ou se
por acaso eu queria comprar algumas
outras coisas
ou seja eu sempre tive essa liberdade de
escolher quais seriam os meus objetivos
e dessa forma
naquela época eu decidi que eu queria
comprar três coisas parece parecem hoje
muito simples mas é um som e um tênis e
uma prancha mas por uma questão de
matemática eu vi que demoraria muito
tempo para com aquele pouco dinheirinho
comprar tudo aquilo que eu queria
e aí eu olhei a situação e pensei vou
ter que criar alguma forma de arranjar
dinheiro e eu fui pensando foi pensando
pensando e analisando até que então eu
vi um primo já um pouco mais velho que
ele estava vendendo chocolate lá no
bairro dele e conseguir um pouco de
dinheiro com isso é decidir bom vou
começar a comprar chocolate dele e vou
vender na escola e dessa forma eu fui
fazendo isso e comecei a testar se o
melhor era vender no intervalo antes do
almoço depois do almoço final de tarde
serra da amostra grátis ou se não era da
amostra grátis ou seja qual era a melhor
maneira de conseguir atingir aquele meu
objetivo e dessa forma foi vendendo
chocolate e eu vi depois de alguns meses
aqueles meus sonhos aquele sonho de
comprar aquelas três coisas se
concretizando
de fato cumprir tudo aquilo e ainda
sobrou um bom dinheirinho pra conseguir
deixar a poupança então eu vi a
importância da liberdade que me foi dada
para escolher o que eu queria e também
do espaço que me deram para que eu
pudesse criar a minha maneira de
conseguir alcançar aquele sonho
já quando eu tinha 16 anos um pouquinho
depois eu estava no ano de pré
vestibular então era aquele ano tenso e
eu sei que aqui não é o melhor lugar pra
falar isso mas eu sempre fui um péssimo
aluno eu sempre fui um péssimo aluno
então na escola tinha um ranking dos 500
alunos e eu sempre estava entre os 50 30
40 últimos né sempre estava lá atrás
o meu pai naquele ano chegou pra mim e
falou assim para mim olha filho esse é o
último ano que eu vou pagar pela
educação
caso você não passe numa universidade
pública ou você vai ter que trabalhar
pra pagar o cursinho ou você vai ter que
trabalhar pra pagar uma universidade
particular e aquilo me deixou um tanto
quanto chocado assim sabe por que eu vi
a situação ali não acreditava que seria
possível reverter aquele quadro então eu
vi toda aquela situação se que até um
pouco triste
e aí logo em seguida foi a primeira
semana de aula eu tava lá numa das
primeiras carteiras naquela tentativa de
você um bom aluno agora e ver o
professor me viu um pouco triste um
pouco desanimado e chegou assim bem
naquele estilo de professor de 3º ano
chegou pra mim e alexandre isso não é um
ano que você pode estar desanimado você
tem que estar com energia será um ano de
desafios não pode pensar assim e eu
falei olha para o senhor tem um problema
ele pegou um pedaço do intervalo para
escutar ele escutou o meu problema e
falou assim para mim faça um plano disso
faça um plano de estudos
quantas horas e vai estudar por dia
quais matérias vão estudar quando quiser
fazer reforço quais matérias que vai
responder mais perguntas
etc ele falou assim para mim eu vou te
acompanhar e de fato toda semana aquele
profissional acompanhava
nem que fosse perguntado se estava tudo
bem se eu tava conseguindo e bem se eu
tava entendendo tudo mas ele foi me
acompanhando
mas pra mim foi muito mais do que me
acompanhar e incentivar
pra mim ele acreditou que eu mesmo sendo
um péssimo aluno conseguir alcançar
aquele objetivo de passar no vestibular
e de fato no final do ano isso aconteceu
graças àquele professora conseguiu
ingressar numa universidade pública no
curso de administração
e já no curso de administração no
segundo ano teve uma matéria de
empreendedorismo que tinha que realizar
um projeto pensar alguma coisa que tinha
que ser criar ea gente junto com um
grupo de amigos a gente criou aquele
projeto e junto com luiz hamilton e o
diego totumi que são colegas e amigos
grandes amigos
a gente decidiu que aquele projeto a
idéia daquele projeto seria um objetivo
seria uma meta e seria um sonho para nós
e vou contar um pouquinho sobre a idéia
desse projeto pra vocês eu tenho uma
irmã chamada laura laura ela tem
síndrome de down e autismo então ela tem
uma idade muito próxima da minha né e
durante toda a minha vida visto essa
proximidade da nossa idade
eu acompanhei a busca da minha família
em conseguir a melhor educação para
laura a melhor maneira de ela se
desenvolver quais eram os melhores
métodos aonde que ela poderia ter mais
independência mais autonomia e onde ela
poderia de fato tem uma qualidade de
vida melhor
quando eu era criança agora recebeu
alguns prognósticos e esses prognósticos
de iriam diziam que devido à
agressividade dela ela teria uma
probabilidade muito pequena e tem
independência de ter autonomia ou de ter
de fato uma qualidade de vida sem que
ela tivesse que tomar doses altíssimas
de remédio
porém a gente não desistiu disso e hoje
ela tem 25 anos e ela apresenta um
quadro muito diferente daquele
prognóstico que foi dito no passado
claro que ela ainda apresenta um quadro
de agressividade e tudo mais mas muito
muito muito melhor do que foi dito
quando eu era criança
isso só aconteceu graças a uma série de
instituições pessoas e organizações que
atendem à pessoa com deficiência e fazem
o máximo de esforço para que essa pessoa
com deficiência desenvolva e dentro
desse contexto
junto com luiz e com o diego a gente
resolveu pegar aquela ideia que era
ajudar essas organizações
se desenvolverem assim administrar em
melhor a terem mais recursos para
conseguir impactar mais pessoas e com
uma qualidade melhor
a gente resolveu pegar essa ideia e
colocá la em prática
em 2010 nós pedimos demissão dos nossos
empregos ea gente começou a trabalhar
por essa organização por esse ideal
e de fato a gente foi ajudando algumas
instituições e buscando recursos com
empresas que financiassem essa
organização que a gente estava criando
para fazer com que aquele sonho fosse
uma realidade é para que ele fosse
possível foram 16 meses onde a gente
ficou sem receber quase nenhum real
panfletando na em sinaleiros para
conseguir ganhar um dinheiro para manter
aquele sonho aceso lavando louça em
vários restaurantes tudo naquele
objetivo de manter aquele nosso sonho
aceso
hoje essa organização já tem seis anos
nós temos mais de 20 pessoas na equipe
nós já atendemos mais de 70 instituições
mobilizamos mais de 1.500 voluntários
recebemos prêmios aqui do brasil de fora
do brasil eu tive a oportunidade de
receber bolsas de estudo para estar nas
três melhores escolas de negócios do
mundo pra fazer com que esse em que essa
idéia se desenvolva cada vez mais e
dessa forma que eu posso dizer pra vocês
que nós eu junto com esses amigos a
gente vive o dia a dia o nosso sonho de
transformar a realidade da pessoa com
deficiência no brasil
ou seja esse sonho já é uma realidade
para nós
porém isso só aconteceu graças à
liberdade que os nossos pais nos deram
para decidir um caminho diferente que
não fosse tão tradicional sair de uma
multinacional sair de aqueles objetivos
padrão para resolver abrir uma
organização então tivemos essa liberdade
de escolher um objetivo diferente também
nos foi dado espaço para criar tentar
errar acertar arrumar fazer de novo ou
seja usar nossa criatividade para que a
gente alcançasse aquele objetivo
e principalmente principalmente as
pessoas que acreditaram
nossos sonhos mesmo quando a gente não
acreditava mais que seria possível fazer
aquele sonho uma realidade
as pessoas acreditaram tanto em nós
tanto em nós que aquele impossível se
torna possível pra gente e graças a isso
a gente pode dizer que hoje nós vivemos
esse sonho
agora esses três itens é algo que todos
nós podemos fazer dia a dia cada
educador
cada professor cada pedagogo cada pai
cada amigo cada pessoa pode fazer isso
pelos outros dia a dia
agora imaginem como seria uma sociedade
se todos nós fizéssemos isso um pelos
outros
imagine uma sociedade onde cada um de
vocês fizesse isso por alguém muito
obrigado obrigado